kinematics is the geometry of motion to
simplify the motion of a pointer finger
the three finger bones are modeled as
narrow cylinders the two joints are
modeled as small spheres each 0.1
centimeters in the diameter so they show
that this right over here and rotating
from the center the finger is mapped on
a cartesian coordinate plane so here's
kind of the first joint of the pointer
finger and while i'm doing this i'm
actually looking at the side of my
left pointer finger and it's pointing
straight up and this is what it looks
like although my the top part this top
section right over here is much longer
for me it's much closer to this middle
section but anyway let's see what they
have to say they say the first finger
bone is 2.4 centimeters long which
actually looks about right for mine as
well the the middle finger bone is
two-thirds the length of the first so
that's this length right over here and
two-thirds of 2.4 is going to be what
1.6 so this distance right over here
we do that in a color we can actually
see
this distance right over here
is 2.4 centimeters this distance right
over here is two thirds of that so
that's 1.6 centimeters and the top
fingerboard is one-third the length of
the first which does seem short but i'll
just go with their numbers so one-third
of 2.4 this is 0.8
centimeters everything we're doing is in
centimeters the center of the tip of the
finger goes from open at zero five so
that point right over there to a closed
fist so when the fist is closed and i'm
looking at my hand doing it right over
here
the finger will look something like this
the pointer finger and so the tip goes
to x comma y they want us to figure out
the x coordinate the x coordinate of x
comma y so maybe we don't even have to
worry about the y coordinate
so let me let me draw this a little bit
larger just so that we can
make sense of it so you have this first
section of the finger it's 2.4
so this is 2.4 centimeters and it's
completely
it's completely horizontal
try to draw it as large as i can so that
we can make sense of all of this
so that right over there is 2.4
centimeters and then it hits this joint
this joint has a radius or it has a
diameter of 0.1 centimeters
0.1 centimeters so its radius its radius
right over there is zero point
zero point zero five centimeters so the
entire length of this section you see
here is two point four five so this
point right over here is at this point
right over here is at 2.45 comma 0. then
you have the next section which has a
length of 1.6 centimeters and they tell
us this is a 45 degree angle
so this right over here
this right over here
is
1.6 centimeters
1.6 centimeters and of course you have
that 0.05 radius again so this entire
length is going to be 1.65
but then we have another joint here
which we can't forget about we have this
joint right over here so let's draw that
so you have this joint right over here
draw it it has a diameter of 0.1
centimeters and i'm drawing it i'm not
i'm definitely not drawing this joint to
scale i'm just trying to make sure we
pay attention to the joint
so let me
draw a little bit
better something like
this
and once again we have another 0.5 so
this entire length if we were to go from
this center to that center that entire
length is going to be 1.6 plus these two
radii which add up to one diameter which
is going to be so it's going to be plus
0.1 which is equal to 1.7 centimeters so
this entire side is 1.7 centimeters
this entire side
is
2.45
so plus
0.05 is equal to 2.45
and then finally this last section
we have
we have a right angle here they tell us
that this is a right angle and this
section right over here is 0.8
so this is 0.8
this is going to be let me make it clear
so
this section right over here just if we
don't count the joint is 0.0.8
but then we have of course
this
we have this
0.05 centimeters so in combination so
plus
0.05
you get
this whole length right over here
actually i don't want to clutter it
this whole length to the tip right over
there this whole thing
is
0.85 centimeters
now how do we figure out the coordinate
of this thing and i encourage you to
pause the video at any time to try to
figure out this and and really just to
save us work let's see if we can just
focus on the x coordinate i'm just going
to try to come up with an expression for
it i don't feel like using my my
calculator just now
so the first thing is let's try to
figure out an x coordinate let's try to
figure out the x coordinate for that
point right over there so where does
that point
intersect
intersect the x-axis so essentially what
is
what is this distance right over here
well it's going to be 2.45
minus
2.45 whatever this distance is
whatever this distance is
and we should be able to use this
distance
given the fact that this is a 45 degree
angle
angle we know this length right over
here this is a right triangle we could
use a little bit of trigonometry
we know that the cosine so this relative
to this angle this is the hypotenuse and
this side is adjacent so we know that
the cosine
of 45 degrees is equal to the length of
the adjacent side so let's say that
that's what we're trying to figure out
let's just say that's going to be a for
adjacent and let me do this in a color
that i haven't used yet so it's going to
be equal to the length of that side a
over the length of the hypotenuse
over adjacent over hypotenuse the
hypotenuse we already figured out is 1.7
centimeters 1.7
centimeters or we could say that a
or we could say that a
is equal to 1.7
1.7 times the cosine of 45 degrees
times the cosine of 45 degrees that's
this length so if you wanted this x
coordinate right over here that x
coordinate is going to be this x
coordinate which is 2.45
minus a
so minus
minus
1.7 times the cosine of 45 degrees and
we don't know what the y coordinate is
we haven't we haven't figured that out
we haven't figured that out yet but the
question doesn't ask us to
let's see if we can just going with the
x coordinates if we can get all the way
to this x coordinate right over here
well this x coordinate is that x
coordinate right over there and so let's
see if we could figure out this length
we could subtract that length from this
x coordinate and get to this x
coordinate and how could we figure out
that length well that length is going to
be the same thing as this length
down here
and this is a completely a horizontal
this is a horizontal line so this is
going to be parallel to that line over
there
if you view if you view this as a
transversal of two parallel lines if
this angle is 45 degrees i'm running out
of colors here if this angle is 45
degrees then this angle is also going to
be 45 degrees
if this is a right angle which it is so
that's a 90 so then this is going to
have to be 45 as well
because 45 plus 90 plus 45 are going to
be 180 degrees we've gone completely
around we're forming a completely
straight line so this is a 45 degree
angle
this is a 45 degree angle so given this
is a 45 degree angle how do we figure
out how do we figure out
how do we figure out this length
right over here well once again
the cosine
of 45 degrees
is going to be equal to the length of
the adjacent side which is what we want
to figure out we don't want i know this
thing's getting messy we want to figure
out this length right over here it's
going to be equal let's call that length
x it's going to be equal to x over the
length of the hypotenuse that's what the
0.85
is so that 0.85 that is the hypotenuse
right of there my apologies for this
messiness 0.85
or we get x
we get x
is equal to 0.85
0.85
times the cosine of 45 degrees
times the cosine
cosine
of 45 degrees so that's this length this
length right over here so if we want
this x coordinate right over here we
just subtract this distance from this
distance so the x coordinate that's what
the whole problem is going to be about
the x coordinate is going to be let me
just write in one color 2.45 minus 1.7
times the cosine of 45 degrees minus
this minus 0.85 times the cosine
of 45 degrees and so this is going to be
equal to
we deserve a drum roll this is going to
be equal to 2.45
minus what is this
2.55 times the cosine of 45 degrees
that's going to be the x coordinate and
we don't know what the y coordinate is
but all they asked us for is the x
coordinate